>> Laura: VERY BIG SHAKEUP ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LEGAL NEED,
LEAD ATTORNEY JOHN DOWD
RESIGNED.
TRUMP REPORTEDLY WAS DISPLEASED
WHEN THE ATTORNEY CALLED ON THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO END THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION.
ANOTHER CONFLICT WAS EXPOSED
WHEN TRUMP SAID THAT HE FAVORED
WHAT DOWD HAD OPPOSED.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU WOULD?
>> President Trump: I WOULD LIKE
TO.
>> Laura: I WOULD LIKE TO.
AS IN TALK TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
IS THE PRESIDENT WALKING INTO A
TRAP?
HARVARD LAW PROFESS OR
HARVARD LAW PROFESS O
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR A
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALL
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALLEN
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALLEN D
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALLEN DER
SHA WITNESSES, AND IN
SAN FRANCISCO, ATTORNEY HA
HARMONY DILLON.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ AND HARMIT,
IT SENDS A CHILL DOWN BY SPINE
AND UP MY SPINE AS A FORMER
DEFENSE ATTORNEY TO HEAR HOW THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO GO IN AND
TALK TO MUELLER.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, WHAT ARE
THE PITFALLS?
>> WHAT I COULDN'T BELIEVE IS
WHAT I HEARD ON TELEVISION
SHOWS, HE ACTUALLY OFFERED A JOB
TO BE HIS LAWYER TO BOB BENNETT.
BOB BENNETT.
I WONDER IF ANYBODY TOLD HIM,
WAS THE LAWYER WHO GOT BILL
CLINTON IMPEACHED.
BOB BENNETT WAS THE LAWYER WHO
TOLD BILL CLINTON IT'S OKAY, YOU
CAN TESTIFY AT A DEPOSITION
ABOUT YOUR SEX LOIF.
THAT'S WHAT GOT HIM -- SEX LOIF.
THAT GOT HIM IMPEACHED.
HE COULD HAVE SETTLED FOR
$750,000.
I CALLED IT THE GREATEST LEF
BLUNDER OF THE -- GREATEST LEGAL
BLUNDER OF THE 20th CENTURY.
BOB BEN THE WAS OFFERED A JOB TO
COME AND BECOME TRUMP'S LAWYER?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT WHITE HOUSE.
HE OF COURSE SHOULD NOT TESTIFY
UNLESS HE ABSOLUTELY HAS TO.
AND IF HE HAS TO, IT SHOULD BE
UNDER THE MOST RIGOROUS
RESTRICTIONS OF TIME, AND TYPE
OF QUESTION, AND HE SHOULD BE
PREPARED TO ANSWER YES, NO, I
DON'T RECALL INSTEAD OF GIVING
LONG, LONG ANSWERS.
BECAUSE THE ONE THING THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET HIM ON, IS
PERJURY.
AND THERE'S NO DEFENSE AGAINST
THAT.
PERJURY IS ONE OF THOSE
SPECIFIED IN THE CONSTITUTION
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
THAT'S THE ONE ISSUE THAT HAS TO
BE AVOIDED AT ALL COSTS.
>> Laura: FULL DILLS CLOSURE, I
WORKED FOR BOB BENNETT IMYEARS
AGO, NOT ON THAT CASE.
HARMIT, THE BIG SWIRLING
CONTROVERSY, OH NO LAWYER WANTS
TO WORK FOR DONALD TRUMP.
FIRST OF ALL, A LOT OF LAW
FIRMS, BIG LAW FIRMS, DON'T LIKE
GETTING INVOLVED IN THESE
POLITICAL MATTERSTOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS, EVERYTHING IS TOXIC.
BUT THIS THIS IS WHAT THE FORMER
ACTING SOLICITOR GENERAL FOR
OBAMA SAID TODAY.
>> I REPRESENTED BIN LADEN'S
DRIVER.
BUT I WOULD HAVE TROUBLE
REPRESENTING DONALD TRUMP.
THE REASON FOR THAT IS VERY
SIMPLE, WHICH IS, YOU KNOW, THE
GUY DOESN'T BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW.
>> Laura: THAT'S COMING FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
WAY THEY HANDLED THE HILLARY
E-MAIL INVESTIGATION, SO FORTH.
HARMIT YOUR REACTION, WHAT ABOUT
WRITTEN ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS,
WHAT ABOUT THIS NARROW AREA IN
WHICH DONALD TRUMP WOULD ANSWER
QUESTIONS, COULD THAT BE
ACCEPTABLE OR IS THAT AS
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ SAYS,
PERJURY TRAP.
>> IT'S LESS OF A PERJURY TRAP
IF THE PRESIDENT ANSWERS WRITTEN
QUESTIONS.
BUT IT CAUSES ITS OWN PROBLEMS.
I DON'T THINK THE.
OF THE UNITED STATES, WHETHER
IT'S DONALD TRUMP, BILL CLINTON,
SHOULD BE ANSWER QUESTIONINGS
LIKE THIS FROM A SPECIAL COUNSEL
UNLESS THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE
OF A CRIME.
ALSO A SHOWING THAT HE'S THE
ONLY PERSON THAT CAN ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS.
ABSENT THAT, THIS IS A PERJURY
TRAP.
IT TROUBLES HE AS A SUPPORTER OF
THE PRESIDENT HE WANTS TO TALK
TO SPECIAL COUNSEL UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT IS A PERJURY TRAP.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS HERE OF HIS LAWYERS
AND OTHER LAWYERS IS THAT MAYBE
THE PRESIDENT ISN'T FOLLOWING
THE SOUND ADVICE OF SOME OF HIS
LAWYERS, WHICH IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM.
A LOT OF LAWYERS WOULD HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH A CLIENT WHO ISN'T
FOLLOWING GOOD ADVICE.
>> Laura: PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ,
THAT'S A BIG ISSUE.
DONALD TRUMP IS A STRONG
PERSONALITY, HE HAS BEEN HIS OWN
ADVISOR AND BEEN PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN PEOPLE SAID NO HE SAID YES.
AND HE USUALLY WINS.
BUT THE LAW IS A VERY DIFFERENT
DEAL.
SO YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THAT,
MANAGING A CLIENT THAT DOESN'T
WANT TO LISTEN.
>> IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT, OF
COURSE.
I LOVE WHAT THE FORMER SOLICITOR
GENERAL SAID, HE WOULDN'T
REPRESENT DONALD TRUMP, HE
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF
LAW.
BUT HE REPRESENTED BIN LADEN'S
DROIFER.
NONE -- DRIVER.
NONE OF THESE, CRIMINALS DON'T
GENERALLY BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF
LAW IF THAT WAS ARE THE BASIS
FOR NOT REPRESENTING SOMEBODY,
ALL OF US CRIMINAL LAWYERS WOULD
BE OUT OF BUSINESS.
THAT'S A PHONY ARGUMENT.
THE BETTER ARGUMENT IS THAT IT'S
HARD TO REPRESENT A CLIENT WHO
DOESN'T LISTEN TO YOU, DOESN'T
TAKE YOUR ADVICE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
SOMETHING VERY STRATEGIC BY THE
WAY.
HE HAS GOOD COP-BAD COP.
HE HAS THE GOOD COPS TRYING TO
MAKE A DEAL WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO LIMIT HIS EXPOSURE TO
LIMIT THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS.
BUT THEN HE'S ALSO PREPARING BAD
COPS.
JOE diGENOVA, CAN GET ON
TELEVISION, GO TO COURT,
LITIGATE I DON'T THINK IT'S A
BAD STRATEGY.
THE PROBLEM IS DOWD DIDN'T WANT
TO BE CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT.
HE WANTED TO BE IN CONTROL OF
THE STRATEGY, ONLY PLAY GOOD
COP.
>> LAURA, I WAS GOING TO SAY, I
AGREE WITH ALLEN.
BUT YOU CAN'T BE GOOD COP AND
THE BAD COP.
DOWD HAD THE SITUATION LAST WEEK
HE WAS CALLING ON THE WHITE
HOUSE, SPECIAL COUNSEL TO LIMIT
HIS INVESTIGATION.
YOU CAN'T BE THAT SAME PERSON
WHO'S NEGOTIATING THE TERMS OF
THE INTERVIEW OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO HE CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
>> Laura: I THINK ALSO --
>> I AGREE.
>> Laura: I THINK, GUYS, WE'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME, BUT YOU
ALSO HAVE TO BRING IN PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT SOMETIMES, IN THEIR LATE
70s, EARLY 80s.
NOT TO BE AGEIST --
>> HEY!
[LAUGHING]
>> Laura: OTHER THAN YOU, DERSH.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO BRING IN
PEOPLE WHO ARE, YOU KNOW, IN THE
PRIME, HAVE EXPERIENCE, SO
FORTH.
I KNOW HE'S INTERVIEWED EMMETT
FLOOD, OLD CLERK OF MINE,
PHENOMENAL.
YOU CAN PUT TOGETHER A TEAM THAT
HAS SENIOR STATESMEN, LAWYERS,
YOU CAN HAVE A LITTLE BIT
YOUNGER.
AND BRING THAT IN.
>> YOU LEFT OUT ONE GROUP.
>> Laura: WHAT?
HE MUST INCLUDE WOMEN.
WOMEN ON HIS DEFENSE TEAM.
>> Laura: 100%.
>> YOU NEED TO HAVE WOMEN ON THE
DEFENSE TEAM.
>> Laura: WE'RE SMARTER.
>> YOUNG PEOPLE, PEOPLE OF
COLOR, PEOPLE WHO ARE WOMEN,
PEOPLE FROM EVERY BACKGROUND.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING
TO GET WHEN YOU HAVE A JURY,
DON'T KNOW WHAT JUDGE YOU ARE
GOING TO PULL, YOU MUST BE
PREPARED FOR EVERY EVENTUALITY.
LOOK, WE KNOW THAT THEY PUT THE
CASE IN THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
BECAUSE THEY WANTED A PARTICULAR
KIND OF JURY RATHER THAN THE
VIRGINIA JURY.
BOTH SIDES HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PLAY THAT GAME.
GET THE MAXIMUM ADVANTAGE OUT OF
THE DIFFERENCES IN JURORS --
>> Laura: WE'RE GOING TO BE
GOING AFTER THIS -- THEY WON'T
HAVE A JURY.
>> GOD FORBID YOU GET TO A JURY
IN THIS CASE.
>> Laura: JURY TRIAL?
>> MAYBE NOT AGAINST DONALD